jail oh boy this story is very tough to
hear day after day thank you very much
jonathan but we need to know what's
going on there
the twin disasters are giving the
presidential candidates one more thing
to fight about today
in california president trump dismissed
scientific evidence
that climate change is behind the
extreme weather democratic nominee joe
biden called him
a climate arsonist who is endangering
americans
wishing has the story speaking under a
smoky haze
president trump blamed the historic
fires on fallen
trees that were not cleared out it has
to be
good strong forest management the
president has pushed the idea for three
years
but california governor gavin newsom
pointed out that only 3
percent of land in the state is under
state and local control
57 percent is under the federal
government
he said that climate change is a much
bigger factor
the science is in and observed evidence
is self-evident that climate change is
real
and that is exacerbating this a
california national resources official
urged mr trump to acknowledge it if we
ignore
that science and sort of put our head in
the sand and think it's all about
vegetation management
we're not going to succeed together
protecting californians
but president trump pushed back it'll
start getting cooler
you just watch i wish science agreed
with you
hey well i don't think science knows
actually it's
science former vice president joe biden
blasted the president
who has rolled back climate regulations
and downplayed the threat of climate
change for years
if you give a climate arsonist four more
years in the white house
why would anyone be surprised if we have
more america blaze
mr trump is ignoring scientific
recommendations on another front
holding his second indoor event in a row
out west with
little social distancing and few masks
this is supposed to be a round table but
it looks like a rally but it is a rally
back in washington the top spokesman for
the department of health and human
services
slammed government scientists in a live
video he hosted on his personal facebook
page
michael caputo has taken the video down
but in it he claimed the cdc included a
resistance unit
and said its scientists haven't gotten
out of their sweatpants
except for meetings at coffee shops to
plot how they're going to attack
donald trump next we spoke with caputo
last night who said he's feeling the
pressures of the job in dealing with
multiple threats against his family
and he claims that's what led to venting
on facebook
happening today here at the white house
president trump is hosting a signing
ceremony
as the united arab emirates and bahrain
commit to normalizing relations with
israel
the agreement